By the way.
Did you buy seven Bentley's that were the same color?
No,
but I put him on seven Bentley's before.
Damn there rolls Royces.
I wanted to ask,
you did give away one when you crashed it,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
I was married at the time,
Robin givens and we were in fast food.
Jane,
we order food and she went in my pocket,
I guess to get some money out my pocket to pay for it.
And she's asking for from condoms came out and she was mad.
So she got in a car and then boom,
she crashed the car into another car that was parked here.
Boom.
And she hit somebody and she hurt their arm and then the cops came.
And so the cops came,
the cops are saying,
Hey,
what happened here?
Right.
And um,
I was afraid of they were arresting me or a so I said,
well nothing happened officer.
Um,
nothing he said and the guy was,
and it was the guy who had broken out my thing,
you know,
so why don't you just take the car,
you know you deserve it because you've been doing a lot.
Cause I didn't want to get rid of that.
I didn't have rice and beans and I didn't want my wife to get in trouble.
If you want to just take it,
you know,
it wasn't that it was around 230 at the time.
So why don't you just take it?
It'd be okay.
And was the guy said,
hey,
don't tell me that.
And then once he said that if I got him,
I got him nothing.
Hey Man,
taking me through this man,
you deserve this.
Take it.
And they took it.
But before that the guy from guy arm was broken and he,
I gave him my money and I'd take the money and then he came back to the police
in my arm.
But it kept him.
Now he can get away from my knuckle to pay to get away from me no more.
Cause he didn't want to mess this deal up with this car cause the guy,
he is not going to get this car.
That's a little coffee.
Don't fucking come near me again.
That hit me.
The Guy,
he's backed off and I said,
go ahead man.
I feel it.
And I took off my work.
I didn't want it to get in trouble,
but they made them give away the car.
Right.
They made it real.
He could cause I went back to my office.
I can my fucking car back going to that.
Yeah,
he got fired.
He probably hearing his name.
I'm going to get that back to the
Indian giver.
One of my car.
Oh No.
Mike Tyson calls you up and says,
give me my fucking car,
man.
Like shit,
it's outside,
man.
I got dammit it.
I take it.